[Music]
how many superheroes are in this movie
did you ever figure out okay so we put
all these trailers
all right I hear this ending scene is
just the last battle is crazy
stupendous goes on forever go see that
Kilmer boy so well want to ask what's it
like when you're on a set with all these
folks and everybody's working out what
are your Marvel muscles like and what's
it like on the set when everybody's like
well some people focus on different
things like Sebastian is really into his
abs that's this thing I'm really into my
legs because I when I go to the beach I
was speedos so I want you to know what
I'm working with
and no it's mbaku over here
[Laughter]
he's a backward I'm gonna show up like
this man why you win so Vietnam Winston
you've you've been a little bit of a hit
on Instagram ladies love to our
Instagram about you how do you know good
car that's first thing it was like it's
a lot to handle
yeah yeah all of ya as they're called
browser come on come on bug mutt after
all I gonna have to pull away and kind
of try to see where they're coming
better you better and I think it's more
of a response to seeing that character
who like unapologetic he you know
represented something that you didn't
always see on screen like a strong man
no but a straw Tom
tall dark skinned gap-toothed man let's
meet my eleven is the new six five
Sebastian Tommy you talked about a few
of the the folks that you were around in
the movie they get in any trouble do
they get okay I love how everybody now
tries to make a big deal you say I was
gonna be sick no I was like he's
referring to the sting that now he's
like trying to make like like I had a
big no no no I was gonna have me I was
gonna ask you is Tom Holland I'll be all
right
they spoil everything nobody crazy then
mission is is would not be in this mode
you mention s I'm out I said Michael
Douglas I'm like is my come in and pour
a teen one singing frozen I mean I'm
just saying yes in the movie at least in
a movie that I was in I heard it might
not be in that in this movie are about
sweeps anymore
dad's in Washington Denzel really Louis
is actually are could be a great as you
looked around what was it like taking in
that you're in a movie that probably is
going to be the highest-grossing well be
involved I always said like I feel like
this movie's gonna bring all those
almanaque records you know I said down I
mean I just feel like yeah you know
you're gonna look on Monday for example
Monday is gonna be crazy just just to
stand there and look around and you see
all these people that have box office
bones dog but no Anthony will be there
so they'll be good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]